[Music]
imagine the Mediterranean Sea is
disappearing old shipwrecks are rearing
their ugly heads as the water drains
around them and Mediterranean cruises
are becoming increasingly disappointing
but for once this isn't the result of
climate change
we're doing it on purpose if we blocked
off the Mediterraneans main water source
from the Atlantic Ocean we'd essentially
be creating a new desert that connects
Europe with Africa this new
supercontinent would not only make
international trade easier but it could
also provide some much-needed renewable
energy resources but what kind of
environmental impact would come with
removing an entire body of water how
could we use the new land and what
happened last time someone tried
something like this this is what if and
here's what would happen if we drained
the Mediterranean if this whole idea
sounds a little familiar it's because it
was proposed back in the 1920s by a
German architect named Herman zorga as
intriguing as circle's idea was the
project never really took off because
for one thing there wasn't enough
concrete in the world to build a dam
large enough to block off the
Mediterranean and on top of that Germany
was crippled by losing the first world
war but times have changed and here we
are desperate for renewable energy
solutions so why not give this idea
another shot what could possibly go
wrong
draining the Mediterranean would be no
small feat it has a surface area of
approximately two-and-a-half million
square kilometers and an average depth
of 1500 meters we wouldn't drain this
body of water the same way that you
would drain a bathtub instead we would
have to focus on blocking off its intake
of the water coming in from the Atlantic
Ocean you see the water in the
Mediterranean is evaporative meaning
that more water evaporates from it then
flows in from rivers and streams the
water that the Mediterranean Sea needs
mainly comes from the Atlantic Ocean
through the Strait of Gibraltar so if we
can cut off that flow we can in theory
drain the sea over time blocking the
water flowing in from the Atlantic would
cause the Mediterranean Sea to decrease
by one point six five meters each year
but we wouldn't want to drain the entire
thing dry instead we could split the sea
into a couple of different water levels
with the middle one being completely dry
land this would allow us to install a
hydroelectric dam at the Strait of
Gibraltar to produce some much-needed
renewable energy for Europe and Africa
renewable energy is always nice but
would it be worth it in this case sure
we have a whole new stretch of land to
develop between Europe and Africa but
most people wouldn't want to move there
it would be a very hot desert probably
the hottest on earth because it would be
so far below sea level at its deepest
points with canyons reaching around 5000
metres below sea level temperatures
could become close to 80 degrees Celsius
to put that in perspective the hottest
temperature ever recorded on earth was
54 degrees Celsius
and because of water from the
Mediterranean Sea is so salty the
uncovered land would just be salt flats
and useless for agriculture soon the
surrounding land would become desert as
well southern Europe and Turkey would
start to dry up and as a result rainfall
would decline which could significantly
impact agriculture in Europe any animals
that live near the Mediterranean
wouldn't have to choose between
migrating away from the coast or dying
because the remaining water would be too
salty and shallow and the negative
effects wouldn't just be limited to our
new super continent all the water from
the drained sea would be redistributed
through the world's oceans causing a
10-meter rise in sea levels cities like
New Orleans Sacramento Amsterdam
Copenhagen and Shanghai would all be
completely under water so unless we want
to be responsible for that we're
probably best leaving the Mediterranean
as it is if we really want to figure out
a way to connect our continents there's
got to be a better way to do it but
that's a story for another what if
[Music]